مشاهدينا نتواجد في هذه الليله التاريخيه
والتي اطلقت عليها هيئه ترفيه للصوت الارض
باجتماع نجوم الفن حيث يضم هذا الحفل اكثر
من 40 فنان وذلك تكريما للراحه طلال مداح
صباح العربيه متواجده اليوم لتنقل لكم
تفاصيل هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بوابات المسرح في استقبال الجمهور الذي
بدا في التوافد على المنطقه مبكرا
للمشاركه في المحفل الاستثنائي الذي
يتابعه العالم عبر اكثر من عشرات الشاشات
التابعه لمجموعه من القنوات المحليه
والدوليه
استمتعوا اليوم واسمعوا الفن على اصوله من
اساتذه الفن في ارض الفن
[موسيقى]
كتبته في جدار وعلى لون السماء الهادي على
الوادي على موتي ومي
لاقي بصوت الارض الله يغفر له رجل عزيز
على قلبي وحبيبي
وتربطني فيها علاقه شخصيه فانا سعدت
بهالمشاركه والله
فرحه الناس بها وبهجتها كذا
انا سعودي يفوق هذا هذا
[موسيقى]
تضاف الى الفن اكيد لانه ما بعتقد صار شيء
من هالنوع قبل بالفن العربي
لا يوصف
فنان راحل وفنان له قيمه كبيره
واحنا في الطفولتنا عشنا معاه في اغانيه
وفي شبابنا كلها في كل اللحظات الجميله
تشريف وواجب وفخور اني متواجد اليوم في
ليله عظيمه ليله التكريم الراحل طلب
المداح اللي عاش معانا مع ذكرياتنا ومع
اغانيهم مع كل كل مشاعرنا في حياتنا
والاجي قاعده تنمد وفن اصيل تربينا عليه
وتعلمنا منه
[موسيقى]
وباركيه عاشتها الرياض اجتمع فيها فنانو
العرب تكريما للمرحوم الفنان طلال مداح ان
شاء الله
تصير ليله من الف ليله وتصير في التاريخ
انتم ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لصباح العربيه محمد خالد الرياض